("Silicon Death" by
Warner/Chappell Production Music)
- You're not going to
give me just a few coins
after everything I've done for you?
- What happened to the
coins I already gave you?
- That ghost hunting business
was a sound investment.
Mario, where are you going?
- Ugh, you just sit
there and you sit there
and never say anything!
I carry on every conversation!
Oh my God!
- Ow, ow, ow, ow, my neck!
Yoshi, you're going to pay for this!
- What? How is this my fault?
- You're throwing bananas!
(both bickering)
- [Voiceover] Don't work so hard.
You're just like your mother.
- What would you know, dad?
You're never home.
- [Voiceover] Where do you think
that money in your ATM comes from?
- Those are my battle winnings, dad!
- Oh sure, I guess you know
everything about everything.
- I didn't say that!
I was just saying that Link always wears
that same stupid outfit everyday.
- He looks cute.
- All he does is talk
to that weirdo Tingle.
- Tingle's a nice elf.
- And is he
still playing the ocarina?
- He uses it to solve his puzzles!
- Are you listening to yourself?
- [Voiceover] Maybe Space
Pirates wouldn't keep
taking over Zebes if anyone
besides me carried a Zero Laser.
- [Voiceover] Wow, that's a
really ignorant thing to say.
More weapons only lead
to more boss battles.
- [Voiceover] Maybe in Dreamland,
but try living in the real world.
- [Voiceover] At Samus, you
should really read this article.
- [Voiceover] What happened
on Planet Zebes is a hoax.
Your government is lying to you.
- Pika, Pika, Pika!
(Donkey Kong shouting)
Pika, Pika, Pika!
Pikachu!
(Donkey Kong shouting)
Pika?
(video game chime)
("Silicon Death" by
Warner/Chappell Production Music)
- Please, Mario why can't
you just teach me to type?
I want to write letters!
- We gotta race.
- Mario?
- We gotta, I gotta race.